it's really interesting that we just had
a conversation
about the sidekick scottie pippen
having an issue with the star
michael jordan in this case
we got the star lebron james
who was having a real issue with the
view of the sidekick
kyrie sidekick the soccer game will you
stop stopping
right there stop right there side
kick nobody sidekick you ask him
all right well if you ask him there you
go
yeah and i think you know and that's how
that's how it happens i mean
these these things are all so fragile
these super teams these great teams
because it sounds good on paper but then
to make it work to make the whole thing
work
all right somebody's got to be able to
be the the lead it's got to be a lead
you can't say we're all in this together
somebody's got to leave this thing
especially
about three the two of them get what
they want two of them eat the third one
is like oh man
why do i sign up for this you know i
used to average 20 somewhere else
now i got to do this sometimes but
lebron
lebron is completely different than
jordan and that
you know jordan is like if kyrie had
said something
said something like this about jordan
well wait should we all right kyrie
i'm sorry to cut you off i'm sorry to
cut you off should we play the sound
from road trip real quick just kind of
set yeah let's do that let's do that all
right i'm going
to interrupt your cooking so wait so
hold on absolutely so basically
to recap in case you've been under a
rock kyrie irving went on his new
teammate
not new teammate but he went on his
teammates kevin durant's uh
podcast um a while back and said this is
the first time that kyrie irving
a couple months ago yep that that's the
first time that kyrie irving
can look over at somebody else
and say oh that guy can make
and take or take and make those tough
shots those clutch shots
quote unquote just like me first time
and a lot of us on the outside
were like well damn what you're saying
about lebron then okay you won a
championship with lebron james
and so finally on richard jefferson and
channing frye's
road tripping podcast lebron had his say
on that matter
when i heard the comment that kyrie made
i i wanted to
one not only find the whole transcript
but also call my people yeah send me the
whole transcript
and um and i heard he had did it on
katie's podcast
and um i was i was a little i was a
little like
like damn yeah once i got the whole
transcript i was like damn
you know i wasn't like all you tripping
i'm
hitting winning shots about my whole
life i was not like that i was like damn
because
um you were there for a couple seasons i
mean i played with
kyrie for three seasons the whole time
while i was there
um i only wanted to see him
be an mvp of our league i only cared
about his success
and um and it just didn't align
it just didn't align and we was able to
win a championship yeah that's the
craziest thing
we were still able to win a championship
and and we could never align but
i only cared about his well-being both
both on and off the floor and
it kind of like it kind of hurt me a
little bit
go ahead mike yeah hurt me a little bit
he said by the way i love i love people
to talk about
when they talk about phone conversations
and they do like that
so everybody does that yeah
we got something so i called my people
and i was like hey man let's get that
whole transcript all right give me the
whole trend the whole thing the whole
transcript i gotta hit
anyway look uh here's here's one of the
many differences between michael jordan
and lebron james
michael jordan if kyrie
had said that about him uh jordan's
looking for him trying to hurt him
that's away from the court then on the
court probably dunk on him so he like
it would be like insane like george
would go nuts on that
and lebron is he's the kind of superstar
who was he's a very inclusive superstar
he is a very
uh interdep interdependent superstar he
always has been
that he had to be talked into shooting
early in his career he's always
his his whole mentality is how do i make
this
better for for me and for everybody else
whereas jordan is just like hey i'm a
sniper i'm a panther
let's go take everybody out um
yeah i wonder why i am a little
surprised though that it
he said it hurt him and i wonder why it
hurt him
because you could turn around mike and
say
make this a kyrie irving very easily
make this a kyrie irving story
of course kyrie irving is going to think
that he's the best one he's
he couldn't accept playing in lebron's
shadow didn't want to demanded a trade
to boston
uh didn't want to accept being in some
type of
offense in boston got to get out of
there too i got to be the man
why would that hurt lebron james when he
knows
kind of like how kyrie irving ticks what
do you think
you just broke it down you just answered
your own question
it hurt lebron james because it's an
insult to who lebron james is
it makes lebron feel like a failure
or that kyrie just completely missed
what lebron was trying to do
you just said it yourself lebron would
prefer to pass than shoot
you know lebron has always been
practically robotic
uh you know a computer program when it
comes to making the right
basketball play no matter the results
how many times over the years we talked
about lebron passing up
the hell it just happened in the finals
you know
passing up danny green a big shot danny
green yeah exactly like
why didn't you take the shot he's always
doing the right because he's wide open
yeah exactly um actually let me go back
to just
the interview and the setting and lebron
had a couple of things we may or may not
get to that he said in the road tripping
podcast shout out to road trip and do a
great job road tripping all the smoke
knuckleheads love these podcasts
nowadays um
i love that lebron i love lebron in
general but i love that lebron i love
that relaxed
uh reflective the most important
vulnerable lebron
so yes i i did like hearing
i did i i was my ears perked up when he
said i was hurt by that that's a that's
an interesting admission to make
you know uh a it shows you that you know
kings have hearts too
but b is like it would have been easy
for him to say
oh i didn't pay attention to that or you
know what that didn't bother me or you
know what
i wish kyrie the best we had a good run
you know i i i don't get caught up in
that kind of thing
but for him to be vulnerable and admit
that hurt me
i think is purposeful and implicitly
answering the question you just posed
why did that hurt lebron james
because lebron james goes out of his way
to bring out the best
in everybody around him lebron james
is ace from painful everybody eats bee
okay that's lebron james's life
lifestyle okay that's lebron's lifestyle
we talk about
mama mentality lebron's lifestyle is
everybody eats bee
and lebron even said it when kyrie
wanted i was like i want to give the kid
the championship dna
like he bends over backwards trying to
accommodate everybody else like
he's that rare superstar if not i don't
know of anybody else that does it this
way we talked about this previously
michael i think it might have been with
any goodwill
most superstars most best players in the
world at their time most kings
there is no room for everybody else to
be great
you got to take a back seat with lebron
james
not only are you in the front seat you
may drive sometimes
you could control the waze you could
pick the music
you could say well we stopping for food
like with lebron james
ask anthony davis i i know i think
asking and i think maybe and i agree
with that
you know 85 90 wayne wade all right let
me just make this last point real quick
dwyane wade the best one of the best
the most mature things dwyane wade ever
did was acknowledge that if we're gonna
go somewhere
as a heat organization this is your team
that's right you gotta you gotta take
control because lebron at that point was
still deferring away
but wade was still brilliant with lebron
james at that stage of his career
anthony davis is still brilliant he
doesn't you don't have to sacrifice with
lebron james
when he's constantly feeding everybody
what did kyrie have to sacrifice with
lebron james
he still had the second best-selling
shoes in the nba
he went to the finals and won for the
first time in his career so what do you
disagree with what i'm saying
well uh a couple you just and you just
drop another one
that kind of illustrates the point right
i agree
90 of what you said with lebron he's not
the guy who says
i'm gonna average 35. he could be the
scoring champ every year that's not his
that's not his mission i don't need to
be the scoring champion i know
he gets both he gets he gets 25 to 30
points a game
and is one end of eating a certain
assist yeah and all that
you can drive the car
but no you ain't you ain't controlling
waze you can drive the car
it's like with lebron yeah he'll give it
to you but he's got it it's got to be on
his terms now
all right
let's stay with this imagery okay you're
right you're right you're not
controlling the ways
well but then again maybe you are when i
say controlling the waves i don't mean
you're giving the direction
i mean are we are we frozen we good hold
on wait for it
there we go all right y'all wait for a
little glitch in the matrix every now
and then
um i'm not saying
that you decide where we're going
or how we're gonna get there if you're
lebron james is
sidekick waze is giving you the most
efficient
way waze lets you know where the cops at
waves let you know where the pothole's
at way let you know where the traffic
jam is waze
does okay lebron james's way is the way
and if you follow lebron james everybody
on this train or on in this car in this
analogy
will get where they want to go if you
follow lebron you come along for the
ride
and you're going to the finals you want
to go to the finals
or you want to go home it's really that
simple yeah
and so yeah you might not be directing
it but we are going to he taking you
where you want to go anyway
so why are you complaining about him
doing the driving and see i and i
just just to tag back to scottie pippen
and then contrast scottie pippen
yeah definitely i like how you can agree
that's your storytelling part one and
two
i like how you did that yeah i knew you
saw a connection kyrie irving
sidekick right so scottie pippen's
sidekick
is kind of disappointed by the way the
story is told
kyrie irving's sidekick said no i'm
going to be the storyteller
and and i think i can be the storyteller
away from lebron
let's just go back he didn't want lebron
there in the first place he did not want
him back now that's shocking to us
based on everything we just said about
lebron james you're in the cleveland
cavaliers
they were trash when lebron left that's
how you got there number one pick
and so when lebron is a free agent in
2014
and goes back to cleveland it was a
great story for everybody else except
for kyrie irving
and the stories are that even before
they won a championship
like he wanted to he wanted to get
traded
and he wanted to get traded right after
the championship
he which i think which boggles the mind
what about this number two selling shoe
bike
you talk about number two selling shoe
what yeah oh what's the number one
selling shoe
but here's what bob why i got to do this
here's what boggles in mind
okay kyrie we talked okay this goes back
to
i said earlier and and you
oversimplified it but you know what i
meant
but you were playing scottie pippen
you're in character when i said michael
got you six rings
okay right
kyrie irving makes
one of the biggest shots in nba history
to beat the warriors to cap the 3-1
comeback
the game before that he and lebron went
ballistic for like 40 points each you
know
ridiculous storyline in game six
you got to show out on the biggest stage
because you rode shotgun with the king
to get there
right kyrie's legacy as a big shot maker
was made in that moment and he didn't
sniff that moment without lebron james
we'll talk about what have you done
without lebron what have you done
without george what has he done with
lebron james
what did he do before lebron james
what's he done since
the celtics got better in his absence
that's right so kyrie irving
i don't even i don't even know if kyrie
irving feels this way he just gives off
the impression that he does
and maybe we're oversimplifying how he
feels but if kyrie irving
has any kind of resentment or any kind
of feeling of being shortchanged
or not getting his props for what he did
in cleveland
then he really is on one then the world
really is flat to him yeah he's on the
planet
you got because on a planet i live on
you
got to the finals with lebron and your
legacy was made
in in that series against golden state
and you are a main man for life you are
clutch you are more than just an
individual brilliant performer
because that guy helped you win so kyrie
if kyrie is that out of his mind then i
don't know what to tell him you know
okay if he really feels like
that he lost the storytelling with
lebron james yeah you're in the
storytelling business
i'll try to be yes try to be you in it
you in it
all right so what kyrie
that meeting your meeting with kyrie is
it's not gonna last that long
because he doesn't like he doesn't like
the way you st he doesn't like what
you're telling the story you like the
way you're positioning this thing
because we know he wants an
alternate ending give me an alternate
ending i don't like this
what you what you're doing so far is
what everybody else is doing
you've got lebron james going back to
cleveland first championship in
cleveland since 1964
taking down the 73 win warriors this is
for the land
it's all about listen lebron's story his
hometown
wait a minute i don't want to be a part
of lebron's story
you say i'm clutch i want to show you
that i'm clutch
in another city i mean how about i'm
going to be
with with kevin durant yeah yeah but i'm
i'm
i'm in i'm not hometown's jerry i'm i'm
a jersey guy i'm from jersey
no no but i'm saying if he wins now he's
the best player
on his own team now like i hope he ain't
taking his madness to brooklyn with him
i know i know they got eight coaches or
whatever
you know and anybody could coach any
giver is he taking that off
to brooklyn yeah okay well i guess well
okay hold on let me cross brooklyn off
the list of contenders because i'm sorry
if if you're sitting if you're signing
up to play with kevin durant
he's the best player on the team you
still ain't the best player in your own
team
you know even coming off the achilles so
i would hope that
you know maybe there was maybe it was
maybe it was more
than just the best player maybe it was
the culture because okay
the culture around any organization
cleveland miami
la it comes from lebron he sets the tone
durant not quite that guy
you know um it wasn't his culture
wasn't his program in golden state you
could debate whether it's his or russ or
hell even sam prestis in oklahoma city
um so maybe
durant is a type of star that is a
better pairing with the personality like
kyrie irving so maybe that's
why kyrie yeah works for him being with
durant
maybe whereas like it's lebron's kingdom
i'm the boss and this is how it's gonna
be maybe durant doesn't care as much and
maybe they play well off each other in a
better way
but there's no question that if they do
contend for and win a championship in
brooklyn kyrie ain't doing it himself
and he's sophisticated enough or should
be sophisticated enough to know that
nobody does it alone
nobody does it alone in this league
that's why james harden won't go play
with him now yeah
nobody does it alone nobody does it
alone mike but just like in the movies
and really for a lot of for a lot of
players it does
come down to how the story is told in
the movies you got
denzel washington didn't do malcolm x by
himself
but sure who was malcolm x
i mean angela bassett was in there uh
you know they were great del ray like
del ray leno's in there like a lot of
people in there yeah
and they were great they were great but
the lead
he wants to be the lead i think he knows
he can't do it by himself he wants you
to leave
yeah you can be the lead nobody watches
the movie it could be the lead and make
her all-time great
and you know or you could be a co-star
and make it all time great i'd rather be
a co-star
in an all-time great ensemble than a
lead in a movie that nobody sees
hey thanks for watching brother from
another on youtube make sure you hit
subscribe
before you leave and be sure to watch us
3 to 5 p.m
eastern time on peacock appreciate you